not everybody has had a chance to read
your statement explain to us why AT&T is
out and apples in well I think the first
thing to say is that Apple was an
obvious choice for the Dow it's the
largest company period it is a strong
leading technology company why do we
know and widely respected if anything we
probably getting comments over the last
few years why it wasn't in the doubt and
second it's a matter of timing Apple
until last June had a stock price north
of seven hundred dollars the way the Dow
was calculated the price matter is the
prices can't be too far apart seven
hundred dollars would have distorted the
whole index and then it's just a matter
of looking at the timing visa another
technology company currently in the Dow
with the price of von braun two hundred
and eighty dollars a share or thereabout
is splitting it stock 441 and that means
that funds tracking the Dow when they
get those four shares for each currently
currently to share they own they will
sell three of them and that will shrink
the technology weight in the index and
bring it down to a number that's far too
low for technology adding apple puts the
balance back and that's really the
reason why we did it choosing AT&T
removing any of those 30 stocks is
always a puzzle and always a difficult
choice but as we looked at it AT&T and
Verizon very similar companies both in
the Dow if anything telecommunications
was somewhat over represented by having
the boat there eighteen t is slightly
smaller has a lower stock price and
those two items suggested that 18t would
come out it has nothing to do with the
price performance of ATT or any other
stock our choices in or out our not
investment recommendations that shows
strictly to make sure the index
represents the market has the right
balance but because AT&T is out we
should feel confident that Verizon won't
be replaced because you want to have a
telecommunications representation there
uh we want to have every sector properly
represented but we have an absolute firm
rule we don't speculate on what we might
do
until we announce it publicly and we do
it so whether it's in there per day a
week a month a year or a century I have
the foggiest idea David
telecommunications clearly now will have
a lower waiting in the dow technology
will have a very substantial waiting in
the dow in terms of the names so in
addition to apple obviously there's IBM
Intel cisco microsoft visa is a stock
that you treat is a technology name to a
degree as well is that over
representation for technology no i don't
think it is what we what we look at we
look at the technology stocks in the dow
we look at both their impact on the
index which is really a proportion of
that prices we also look their market
value we compare that to the sp500 which
is the key professional institutional
measure of the US markets we compare it
to the market so wrong when i say
overall every stock out that down to a
one as small as 10 million dollars which
is really tiny and we see the balance of
technology stocks healthcare consumer
staples consumer discretionary so on and
so forth across all the sectors and we
try and get a reasonable balance we
never hit it exactly in the nose we're
only working with 30 stocks and clearly
some are very big compared to others
David you said it yourself the sp500 is
the key institutional measure of the US
stock market today 2015 what's the value
of a price-weighted index and the the
first two things that stand out is one
the history goes back to 1896 and if we
haven't learned anything else about the
market it does strange things from 2896
the the more you know the better you are
the longer the data series the better
chance you have of figuring out what's
going on so that long history is very
valuable the Dow I because it's been
there for so long because it has the
support of the Wall Street Journal over
its entire history including now is very
well known very widely respected I've
had a company say they don't want to be
in the dowry don't want to even be they
don't want to be considered for the Dow
and the fact that you know we're talking
this morning suggest a lot of people pay
attention to the dow jones industrial
average